Before we dive into the canvas let's take a look at what we'll be building.
>> Huh. You know, it looks like there's a lot going on there.
Shouldn't we start with something a little simpler?
>> How about this one?
>> Oh, this is a lot better.
We can totally build this within a lesson or two.
But I've got one question.
Why exactly are we building a meme generator?
>> That's a good question.
Let's say you have a website that you want to add some sort of chart or
maps to, like the resume project we did in JavaScript Basics.
It is possible to do that with some artful positioning of HTML tags in CSS or
even Flash, but it's much easier to do with Canvas.
Right, Canvas has a set of functions that allow us to draw shapes, images, text,
and patterns.
And instead of working through a bunch of examples with charts and
data, we thought it'd be fun to make some memes.